so today's topic apparently somebody who
was very involved in cancer culture got
canceled so it's from teen vogue
this is the remaking of america in real
time on the basis of equity rhetoric
that is essentially unfair that is the
goal
and if you don't go along with it you
will be cudgelled if you refuse to go
along with this stuff you will be
cudgeled
the media will simply lie to you okay
when i talk about the cudgeling
let's talk about the cuddling for a
moment so over the weekend
in what has to be the most amusing turn
the you remember that alexi mccammon was
going to be the editor of
teen vogue that great prestigious
publication teen vogue not just vogue
teen vogue it's my petty he's team vogue
not any though teen vogue you know the
little sister team
well now it turns out that one of the
people who backed alexi mccammon to
ouster
a senior team teen vogue staffer
election camera was thrown out because
alexa mccammon when she was 17 wrote
anti-asian tweets that was a decade ago
now a senior teen vogue staffer who
backed lexie mccammon being fired
it turns out that this lady wrote a
bunch of
tweets back in 2009-2010 using the
n-word
christine david senior social manager at
teen vogue in 2009 wrote two tweets to a
friend
identifying him as a n-i-g-g-a
and in 2010 used that word in a joke
tweet the friend appears to be white
davis
david says in multiple tweets shoes of
mixed irish and filipino heritage
so not a black person so you don't get
to use these sorts of terms right
well filipino technically are blacks
yeah they're the black folks
of asian people someone i know that's
hey man basketball stand up all my
davids
wanna shoot them david mccammon 27 and a
rising reporter at axios have been set
to take the top job at teen vogue before
her past tweets
set off a firestorm among teen vogue
staff after the atlanta shooting
left asian americans dead mccammon and
teen vogue parted ways
that's the gist of the story one person
was like you need to leave because
you're
you're not good for this paper and then
they found out that she made tweets 10
years ago so they said you're fired
and then one of the person that says
you're fine also had some tweets 10
years ago
so she got fired everybody got fired i'm
just trying to find out what happened
yeah
your tweets 10 years ago was garbage
you're five well
your tweets was garbage you're fired no
you're fired is that what happened what
happened that's what happened
until one [ __ ] was like i'm good i
don't have any problematic tweets and
they're like oh
congratulations david he's like but
problematic facebook posts
and then that's how that escalated no
rough
the only reason i'm not getting fired is
because i didn't have a twitter tenure
but i had a facebook
and i can assure you if i go far enough
in my timeline i should get
i should get fired just for cringe yeah
that's for sure do some
facebook cringe i got me of course i'm
getting i'm getting i'm getting outed
i'm getting out too so i'm getting fired
too because the memes
and it's just comedy but people don't
get that should people be fired for
making
terrible tweets 10 years ago should
people be fired for doing
terrible tweets 10 years no i don't
think they should
i'm not for the canceled culture but i
feel like i'm repeating myself such a
naughty issue guys
i don't know these people just doing
this stuff is so stupid the amount of
virtue signaling you get to see every
day online it's just like but dude
don't you think don't you think don't
you think they [ __ ] created a problem
though
the problem was created by them for them
there's some fubu
it's for them by them bro you know what
i mean so
i'm not for cancer cultural never never
been for cancer culture
you should cancel him nah man that's not
how things work
if you believe in cancer culture and
then you
do something that you are against your
rules
ain't mine i wouldn't have done so but
you think i'm garbage for that
which is fine since you're so right then
yes by your rules
you should be canceled if that's your
rules hey man hey man listen
the same problem these people having the
same problem that their jackson's been
having
everyone's virtue signaling like they
have skeletons in their closet
this is why i already told y'all and i
come out every day and say
my stinks i got some doo-doo back there
i got some doo-doo back there for sure
if you look deep enough you'll find some
do but you know what i know if i look
through your probably got some doo-doo
back there too we all got some do do
back there it's all good to hold each
other accountable
but when you think you're righteous and
better than other people
when you're not we're not we know we're
we know we're not we know ooh
girl i said and done some problematic
things
of course but we we're not going to
claim that we're better than anybody
but you know what it's better it's like
church yes it is like church
everybody come in but go go ahead oh no
please
finish your sentence no no you want to
trigger me finish your sentence i don't
need please no no please you're you're
triggered
no no i'm not not even yet yo chat is he
triggered not yet
but finish your sentence and i assure
you i will please finish your energy yes
but please finish your sentence
just finish your sentence finish your
sentence what do you think it's like
church go ahead
it's like church that's all i'm gonna
say because you know
i don't need to say anything else
because you already know if i was in
here
you know i said it's like church and
[ __ ] it's like
church okay these brothers you're gonna
go to church and they're gonna be
pointing fingers
and everything and stuff and gonna be
like oh you know the pastor's gonna come
up on that stair
and they'll be like you know you sinners
this sinner ah you cannot sin not
you cannot you cannot tie you can't and
then this [ __ ]
worse than everybody in the church put
together pointing
fingers and everything in every
direction
everybody he [ __ ] everybody up in
here he [ __ ] you
you you your daughter everybody
everybody up in here
and it's not even just a pastor or the
deacon or whatever
you know i mean it's not even that it's
the people at church
this is story time with preach if you
want to see the rest of the story go to
the patreon here's the thing right i
don't think that the problem of
cancer culture per se is as per evasive
as
people make it out but i think this kind
of puritanical
i've not done any wrong but i want to
throw stones at other people is
you know even on this channel sometimes
i think we give you guys the impression
that when we look at people's problems
and all this stuff we're like
i there's a lot of stuff that we've done
in [ __ ] up ways me personally i've
already mentioned like the fact that as
a teenager how violent i was
right i'm not a perfect person and i
never want to give you guys the
impression right
i think if you go through life putting
that out i just i rarely believe it i've
been broken in a lot of ways
but what i do think is really
interesting is that
we don't give people any opportunities
for growth or change
or accept that who they are 10 years
later is somehow different
yeah but you have to be held accountable
for the reason when you were 20 you said
something like
what's the purpose of this kind of
dialogue this is so odd to me
and so who benefits from this it's just
everyone's coming out here
with with fake ass instagram accounts
and all these filters
and and people are trying to live their
lives like that they're trying to live
their lives
like there's an instagram filter on it
and i'm like we know that's not real i'm
just not a fan of it
and i think we need to kind of drop that
kind of attitude we can criticize
people's behavior but
not the best thing without saying fire
them let's give people a chance at
real red redemption arcs but that's my
thoughts all the people that are
virtuous signaling
are often the people that say that they
believe in rehabilitation
but then you go and cancel people so
so you don't believe in rehabilitation
you don't believe that people
can rehabilitate themselves not unless
you have to pay for their time
exactly rehabilitation is actually like
redemption
is the opposite of canceled culture when
you don't allow someone to excuse
themselves
don't allow someone to explain himself
just cancel that
person he doesn't need to be that that
is the opposite of rehabilitation
even beyond that it's just getting
outraged at things that really don't
matter
oh yes you know what they said 10 years
ago who cares why do you care so much
you mean to tell me that you are the
exact same person you were 10 years ago
do me a favor go on your facebook on
your facebook
hit that memories and go check some of
your posts that you wrote
[ __ ] forget that how about you how
about you let me see your recent group
chats
we gonna get exposed all right whether
you say it on a public platform or say
in private it's still the same stuff
you want to expose we can expose let's
all get exposed it's so stupid no
nobody's safe from that and everybody
did some egregious [ __ ]
everybody you don't even think it's
egregious now if we read it we're like
oh i could definitely make that
i could definitely have you burnt to the
stick we can do that we can do these
stupid witch hunts they're so boring
yeah that's just my thoughts anything
else
all right leave your comments below
foreign